on april 26 apple made a change to its
ios software and anyone using an iphone
began to see this the app tracking
transparency prompt apple began
requiring apps to give users a choice
ask them not to track you or allow them
to track you across other apps and
websites
now
months later that one software tweak is
having a huge impact on e-commerce and
while the change gave apple users more
control over their data it may mean that
you'll be paying more for stuff whether
you use apple products or not here's why
first here's a number for you 84 percent
even though apps have a chance to
explain why they want to track your
activity
users are asking apps not to track them
about 84 of the time now that they have
the option to opt out according to app
analytics provider flurry and that has
jolted big tech platforms like facebook
and snapchat and bumble companies that
make money by serving you targeted ads
in recent earnings calls tech executives
have blamed apple for a slowdown in
revenue growth our advertising business
was disrupted by changes to ios ad
tracking overall if it wasn't for
apple's ios 14 changes we would have
seen positive quarter over quarter
revenue growth in a statement apple said
a user's data belongs to them and they
should get to decide whether to share
their data and with whom
[Music]
okay so multi-billion dollar companies
are complaining about revenue why does
any of this matter for you
we'll get to how the change is impacting
your wallet in a minute but first you
have to understand how it's impacting
millions of small businesses that rely
on social media advertising to reach
customers
the biggest impact is because of how
sweeping the change was and how suddenly
it took place as a principal at true
ventures fiona o'donnell mccarthy
invests in early stage startups and
helps get them off the ground she says a
lot of the ceos she's in touch with have
seen their digital marketing costs soar
since they can't target customers as
easily so what's happening across the
board is that advertising is less
precise because customers are opting out
of sharing data across apps it's more
difficult to have a complete picture of
someone's behavior or preferences how
much more are these businesses these
advertisers paying to reach customers
we're seeing companies spend 30 to 100
percent more in order to acquire a
customer online not only are social
media ads less effective right now but
business owners like the founder of
consumer warranty startup upsy say
they've also gotten a lot more expensive
we've seen it jump on facebook of 135
percent just from a cpm standpoint
so it has gotten insanely expensive to
advertise on places like facebook the
owner of belmonelli jewelry says her ad
prices are eight to ten times more
expensive even though the ads themselves
aren't as effective because she can't
easily target customers who might want
her product
my jewelry ad might now show up
in front of
you know some in some 50 year old man
speed and 50 year old men don't buy my
things
so so that's been the big difference
what's more the privacy change has made
it harder for companies to know if their
ads are even working since it's become
harder for social media companies to
track what you buy after you see an ad
so what does all of this mean for you
the consumer well if you're an iphone
user of course you have more control
over your data but even if you're not
this all still applies to you
first you might start paying more for
products
some businesses say they're raising
prices to help offset higher marketing
costs sports nutrition company ath
sports told me it had to raise prices
five to ten percent and boost the price
of standard shipping from five dollars
to eight dollars
and clothing company sozi says that in
addition to supply chain constraints
marketing costs are making it more
urgent for them to do things like reduce
their welcome offer reduce rewards
points and charge more for return
shipping secondly mobile ad executives
say that new apps that would have been
free may start charging you since
they're looking for alternative ways to
make money and third you may notice that
the ads you're used to seeing in your
social media feeds and in real life look
a little different on your devices if
you opt out of tracking you may start
seeing ads that seem out of left field
and in real life you'll notice tech
savvy brands appearing in totally
unexpected old-school places think
billboards and catalogs and even radio
ads
[Music]
we've all felt pressured into buying a
store's overpriced electronics warranty
you're going to hear more and more
digitally native brands on the radio
you're going to see more companies start
podcasts and blogs you're going to see
more companies focus on the inherent
network effects that are part of their
uh physical or digital product
and that's going to be required in order
to scale
meanwhile those big tech companies say
they're currently working on developing
tools that will let advertisers serve
you personalized ads without getting
your personal information
but what those tools look like and how
much those ads cost remains to be seen a
lot of the business owners i talked to
for this story say they appreciate
privacy concerns and understand the need
to strike a balance data can help
companies find consumers but it can also
help consumers find products that we
love
but how much our data is worth and how
much we're willing to share is a
negotiating process that has only just
begun now i'm curious where you stand on
the privacy issue are you willing to
allow apps to track your activity online
or do you prefer to opt out let me know
why by leaving me a comment and if you
want to know more about how tracking
works check out the links below for
videos from my colleague wsj tech
columnist joanna stern and last but not
least if you found this video
informative please hit subscribe so you
can join me as i cover more news that's
impacting our lives see you next time